the tigers are going to send out
left-hander tyler alexander making his
13th start of the season he's faced the
white sox 12 times in his career
including five times as a starter
got him
foul tipped it into eric hoss's glove a
strikeout to start this misty tuesday
one down luis roberts ships this ball
into left center field and robert is on
his way to second
with a one-out double luis wasn't going
to wait around and he's at second base
it's 11 game hitting streak for luis
grandahl pops it up right side of the
infield
scope
under it battling the wind and he takes
care of it in a good inning for tyler
alexander 14 pitches and he strands a
one-out double dallas keiko goes to the
mound he's on for his 29th start his era
at five and a quarter
chopper to first abreu for kykel who got
there in time for the out and the punch
from sherwater the umpire at first nice
play the coordination between jose abreu
and dallas kykel nothing nothing bottom
of the first runner at first one away
and there's a fly ball twisting down the
right field line and it's going to land
fair
in the corner
scope's going to be sent around third
the throw by anderson on a relay and
they got him
boy was that a weird play it'll be a
double for grossman
engel's throw came all the way back to
second base where anderson was that was
a very aggressive send by ramon santiago
at third
and they get scope at the plate it's
been a pretty good rhythm here in a
challenging afternoon
and he strikes out garcia to end the
second a one two three frame for tyler
alexander frustrating the white sox
early on certainly power wise he's been
tough against our ball club this year
struck him out first strikeout for kykel
very good change up this one just off
the plate which is exactly where you
want to throw it if you're ahead in the
count age 25
300 at bats and a 166 batting average
soft ground ball chopped up the middle
bare handing paredes throws to first and
he got him that's a good play but he saw
paredes on a soft tapper over the
mountain by a speedy runner yeah that's
the only way he was going to get him
runner at first one out third inning
nothing nothing
and the first pitch is lined out to
right again and this one's going to get
to the wall
hernandez making his way to third
tim will have a double
and the relay throw got past the two
infielders but the runners will stay put
that's a double see how drenched the
field gets
this is over the head of the left side
of the infield and brings home one here
comes tim anderson he scores as well and
the infield drawn in robert plays right
into it and hits a mallet shot for two
34 driven in sox have the lead that's a
cutter tries to keep it away and luis
pounds it into the ground that's why
hitters love to get with the infield in
1-0 smoke to center a bray you sized
that one up beautifully
and the socks now have four straight
hits big numbers and in a single inning
in a hurry ground ball to third base
backhanding at candelario down to second
one paredes related first they turn the
double play beautifully done candelario
to paredes to scope let them know that
it's not going to be a throw in the
towel type of day
the 01 stroke to left
into the corner that is down and up
against the wall reyes will drip dig for
second he is there with a pop-up slide
it's a lead-off double for victor reyes
the second double for the tigers today
now the 2-2
a looper over the glove of tim anderson
akil badu responds so do the tigers
they've cut the lead in half a job well
done by a couple of young outfielders
and reyes and badou the response so
important and this team has done it time
and time again
on the ground rolling and rolling and
hernandez fading away saves the lead for
the socks cesar with a rangy effort
catcher going down the line is not going
to beat this dude off a good range to
his left and it's out of the air
the 2-2 drilled to left center field and
deep and that ball will
bounce a couple of times before reaching
the wall monkatta wants to do three
here's the throw from good
in time to get him
the little things again chef hitting the
cut off man in a great position to catch
the ball and apply the tag and you can
see it right there he takes him on the
helmet there's a keel badou he drove in
the tigers lone run an rbi single last
time up
ground ball through the right side
another base hit for akil badu
cameron will try and score and he will
do so to tie it akil badu does it again
well ship this time he did it to the
right side he pulls the ball and gets
past abreu you knew that it was going to
go into right field as a matter of did
daz get a good enough jump he certainly
did so
both rbi's both runs driven in today
from aquila badou
tim is short sets and throws and that
will do it the tigers leave him loaded
576 slugging percentage against detroit
in his career
balls crank to right and down off the
warning track and the wall brayu
tees off on the first pitch he sees four
a two out double jose hits this one hard
it's probably out of the strike zone but
it certainly was to his liking
another 2-2
in the air to center
good job reyes is there excellent job by
tyler alexander he strands two more
reyes old for three in his career
against jace fry
in the hole it's short anderson high
throw over the head of jose abreu victor
reyes will be awarded second base that
went into the camera well i believe and
that's the way to start the sixth white
sox could not take advantage tigers
trying to do that 2-2 hit on the ground
pass a pitcher run will try to score
anderson's throw to the plate is late
grandahl's convinced that reyes is out
and we'll see if the white sox challenge
it that was a risky play by anderson but
it was a good throw good tag by grand
all
we'll see if tony challenges it and he
will he's out that is surprising
from what we saw at least
so the tigers have made two outs at home
plate today
it's a fielder's choice for badou and
it's a 6-2 put out
hotly contested series so far tigers and
socks as this goes to shortstop it is
anderson it's hernandez and it's a
double play
six four three the sox little escape job
two on to start the inning announcement
on third two outs and leaves it up to
nico goodroom the 1-1 between the line
drive base hit into right field tigers
take the lead
grossman in the score 3-2 tigers here in
the seventh inning nico goodrum delivers
a big two-out hit well that's the
already hitting right there the pitch
was away did not try to pull it nice
buggy whip to put the tires out of five
bases loaded facing aaron bummer
neal one right side finds a hole
goodrum is home cameron hustling home he
is there without a throw
and the out made at third base to get
esau paredes but not before victor reyes
punches the ticket another four hit game
for reyes two more runs scored his
slider
has not gotten hit nearly as hard as tim
sends this ball out towards center field
and falling down in front of reyes
one run home it is five to three now tim
anderson's second hit of the afternoon
sucks creep closer three two two outs
the runners will be off for the pitch
he sits him down
and closes it out the tigers beat the
white sox
5-3
tigers are now 8-3 in their last 11 ball
games all
against first place teams
you